>> Programming with objects is the predominant way of developing software today.
>> Code is organized into pieces called objects. You can use objects written by
other people to create your own programs.
>> That way, you get to stand on the shoulders of giants instead of having to
start from scratch every time.
>> In this lesson, you'll look at lots of different examples of objects. You'll
learn what they can do and how to make them do it.
>> At the end of this lesson, you'll be able to write a program that draws a
rocket, flying from earth to mars. I think you'll be impressed with what you'll
able to do.
>> I'm really excited of what you're going to learn this lesson. Let's get
started.